[音楽]
voodoo
今日は写真の可能性について皆さんにお話しします
硬くて
後はこうした大きな店
これは日系ブラジル人の現場作業員
日本のものづくりを支えるって
あなたの車んあなたのか年あなたの持てるものを作ったかもしれないんで
1990年イン今から約30年毎
法律が変わって日系ブラジル人たくさん日本に来ました
にケーソン水までの人たちが日本に働くことを認められたからです
ケーキの位日本に働くことを目的に来る
で稼げるです
先のでの持ち主も1990年に日本で稼ぎに聞いた
日系ブラジル人おひなたさんです
ここで約30の今井で日制労働者の暮らしにタイムスリップしてみましょう
[音楽]
ん
始業ベルが鳴る指差し確認
安全よし
危険汚い筆
3型と呼ばれる仕事でも日本人が嫌がる夜勤でも進んで行った
ミスをしないように
二行出さないように
ner こと時間を守ること
日本人とかジム人の間にはいろんな違いがある
言葉は分からない中で仕事をするのは大変
作業日は今日もマクロになったあっ
タバコ休憩ほっと一息こうして1日が悪
家に帰ったら狭い基準 a よりをする
村自分残してきた家族にはいつは英語だろうか
手紙を書いても届くのは半月先
携帯電話なんて ba なものはない
早部気持ちを胸に電話ボックスのリスに習う
こげが30年前の出稼ぎ労働者の口らしいです
これは僕が撮った写真です
だけど実際に3 u 2枚もたた写真ではない
30年前を再現した写真です
この後ヘッドは今た理由を話す前に少し僕のことをお話しします
僕がブラジルの港町生まれました
うひそが日本からから自分は断ってきた
に形成
ブラジルでは亀が安をやってみました
小さな頃からカメば身近にあげました
でも本格的に写真撮るようになったのは日本に切ってかな
今から28年前僕も
出稼ぎ労働者として日本に来たんです
大変なことも多かったけどいい人にも巡り合いました
僕に写真教えてくれたのが滝口さんです
単調な出稼ぎ生活が髪を手にしたことで少し楽しくなった
を見にダルいも図書に怒り滝口さんをよく撮影に出かけた
でも
何か足りなかった
ただの木々写真じゃなくてみすじが感じられる
その写真を撮りたいと思った
そこで
自分の物に立ち返った
約30年枚
出稼ぎに来たーー
最初の世代の朽木を残したい
このヘッド始まった理由は
あの頃に自分が体験した氏の記録にすることでした
最初の世代が道を拓いたから
今である
その努力を96したい
その努力に感謝したいという思いを込めて
当時の再現写真を解くことは決めました
それが先ほどを見せた書士です
この出稼ぎぽジェッツ1を撮影するのに3年かかりました
その後
等兵と共有したいと思いました
写真が展示さげて最初の出稼ぎ世代にも今の出稼ぎ世代にもメッセージが届きました
たくさんの人に見てもらってブラジル人だけじゃなく日本人にもメッセージが届きまし
た
自在の投げたともにり稼ぎは少しずつ形を書いている
日本人ずっと総務人たちも増えてきたと言っ
今では日本人と同じように活躍にする人たちも出てきている
その新しい出稼ぎ世代は撮影したのが出稼ぎ500人数
モデル
予備に
大学生
スも通り
坂
社長など
皆さんが映画に分けましたか
ここにはみらゆの規模があります
最初の出稼ぎせ際は日本の社会の中で自分たちの小さな居場所をつくりました
日本に運が自分たちが快適に生活できるように
交通交通と動力をしてきました
世代が彼は3
日本語を勉強して日本の社会で活躍する人たちも出てきました
焦げからの出稼ぎ世代はどんな形になるでしょうか
若者たちにはパイオニアが使った環境がある
まずはしっかり日本語を勉強に進むこと
そして向上心を持つこと
日本とかじるそたちのアイデンティティを持たせ際も新しいでカセ
これからは日本の社会で日本人十ブラジル人が一緒に活躍していけるでしょう
さてここまで写真の可能性用として
出稼ぎは過去と未来を話してきました
写真は秘密を現と言いますか
ほんとこいつそれだけでしょうか
写真は各という記録を残すことができます
そして未来という希望を打つこともできます
僕がそう思います
これからは
写真の可能性を信じてー
僕も写真撮ってきます
[拍手]